[Musica]
signori benvenuti e bentornati e ben
ritrovati a bossi fa poi il programma su
youtube dove io innescato con dentro
cose stranissime manco in terrorizza
della puntata di oggi vedo già il mio
pacco in lontananza leggo america il
crunch quindi sicuramente sarà credo del
cibo americano
beh non mi sembra chiarissimo che questo
non è cibo napoletanamente let's go bay
allora siccome si tratta di crunch quel
rumore che fai quando maschi delle cose
croccanti adesso proviamo ad aprirlo e
scopriamo facciamo prima però serve
l'apprezzamento c'era traccia come siete
forbici non farebbero del male neanche
la mosca lesbo open this oggi ho
particolarmente fame quindi se mi
mandate cose buone
io sono con te la musichetta e di prassi
ci mettiamo perché sai vedere che ci
mette l'impegno ma dividono vi vorrei
far vedere l'interno quindi vi piego il
pacco verso di voi non fate riferimento
ci sono un sacco di cose sono i dolci
prima cosa di oggi mi sarà una roba
piccola
abbiamo detto il cibo americano prima
che tirò fuori un biscotto della fortuna
però vediamo questo cenci scorta della
fortuna perché stia preparandosi sono
male abbiamo vedere se dentro a questa
tecnica si discute la fortuna come
funziona
si rompe all'interno c'è un bigliettino
che tira le sorti la tua vita puoi
trovare qualunque cosa se la cerchi nel
posto giusto ma non c'è selena gomez ma
dentro è esiste la salsa di marshmallow
march meno sono le caramelle come panna
vela crema che colpa ne parliamo
credo sia la cosa meno salutare nel
mondo perché già il marshmallow e una
caramella il suo più lo scegliamo la
facciamo iniettare una crema o la cosa
più [ __ ] che abbia mai visto sul
pianeta come e buu e magia
tonfo per la mia vita cambiò proprio kit
i kit sono ben ems sono buonissimi
quest'anno davanti fino a domani mattina
possiamo attivare così dopo buon anzi
metodo toglie davanti next
ci sono che filippo ma adesso male ma
questi andavano quando io avevo 8 anni è
stata una bella infanzia e l'ultimo
esemplare immanente sony sono estinti
non li vendono più navi portato
esattamente dove l'ultimo fare lo
mangiano più next gloria aaa che ci
vuole c'era un po di succo crei un po di
latte sta roba qua secondo me la notte
su si era andati coloranti che ci hanno
messo
[Musica]
ma è tutto buono ha mandato un pacco di
roba buona
non lo so leasys quando c'è crisi
[Musica]
mamma mia se riuscissi a capire come si
era salvata dal 3g al cioccolato
all'arte easy e cioccolato al latte
insomma roma esageratamente strana
invece era sufficiente cialde e molto
giapponese questo testamento di logici
se vogliamo metterla brocchi non mi fa
paura
[Musica]
però il piano per il pieno di mad o di
burro d'arachidi mamma mia che bomba
madonna incredibile così incredibile
duro della chitarra che di nettare degli
dei
c'è veramente incredibile next è poca
cosa certo che le cagate inventano
signore o la coca cola non so troviamo
lì madonna se sadico che formavano a
questa una chimica tadic ha incredibili
cover è buono ma non ha senso cioè
bongiorno demi moore è una barretta di
cioccolato non capisco io però dovrebbe
essere una barretta di cioccolato sarà
nel film e ho aspettato molto più
filante non lo sa di mars massimo basso
che si ma beirut
vabbè next 2 watermelon artificiali
flower show at me lo spray cioè tantum
verde questa roba
mio dio mio dio è uno spray al melone ma
sto male
l'impatto è orribile su un tipo plus poi
e buonisti c'è devi superare il primo
millisecondo dopo i primi secondo il
buonismo quindi un misto tra dolore e
piacere
wow abbiamo delle wild about nerds sono
dei danni in scatola era detto una cosa
strana da mangiare provera diciamo che
fanno fanno crack cranici quando le
mangini sono molto croccanti prossimo
muore sono micidiali alberona è questo
che cosa dovrebbe mai essere mini donna
sono delle mini ciambelle coperti di
zucchero homer simpson per i bambini
sembra veramente buona non lo so
proviamo non so se ripiena in quella
mini ciambella di zucchero molto ieri da
ciò il volatone buono allora questi sono
veramente strani avenance al caramello
quindi siamo nelle due cose che a me
piace un sacco quindi a men's di brutto
non so come possa essere al caramello
però veramente sta morendo una roba che
gli piace un sacco ad un'altra mica c'è
un sacco di test
sono dei meno caramel wow
credo non so se l'avreste mai detto
m'hai che sono proprio così
sarà un buon viaggio allora mi stavo
tenendo quasi per ultimi questi perché
mi suscitano tanta curiosità e sono
sempre qualcosa da caprari menez però il
tipo e tipo la nutella menù della mensa
e mentre questo è la stessa roba però
con gli ore e ore
proviamo a ai ragazzi da crederlo però
c'era la nutella due parole con queste
cose dentro un what beyrut ci sta il
fatto è che mimì indisturbate ci abbia
queste cose sopra mi disturba tariffe
tra buono c'è sicuro che quando non è
che lo mette in dubbio
file della nota questione sole national
bank è il pane che partivamo l'altro per
vedere se dunque ci sta di brutto
leo nutella fermerà in futuro tutti
insieme magari la prossima volta
buster finger non è un videogioco una
barretta di più tardi di cose dovete
capire che gli americani c'è uno
statista del delle note delle miniere il
9 o burro d'arachidi cioè 7 statista del
burro d'arachidi ma c'è una ragione ai
buoni simbolo da chi non so spiegare
cos'è qui ce lo mettono anche nella
dell'olio del carburante della macchina
però è buono e veramente un wow sa di
burro la clip è l'ultimo dei nostri
dolci di giudei
ho tenuto per ultimo perché era
gigantesco arpat sono gli ore of chaos
ostuni ore ostuni permettetemi se
stavolta non uso il latte però stanno
testando giusto quindi easy
il discorso è che gli ore o più o meni
maggio per i cavoli miei tipo come a
merenda
se bellissima ingiallisce alle ore o
superiore o direttamente quindi non lo
so io mangerei c'è preferenza al
migliore o direttamente nel latte però
sono buon sangue di oreo ragazzi
quest'episodio di unboxing parigi e
finisce qua ringrazio america inc lancio
la garmin fornito tutto questo ben di
dio e ricordatevi al primo appuntamento
se andate sul sicuro faceto ragazzi 6
video è piaciuto lasciato come non mi
piace anche vari giacomino notiziare
sera se dovessi d'ischia temi e noi ci
vediamo alla prossima
libero bari
[Musica]
ma